gentlemen it was an absolute blast
watching you throughout season five i
gotta say man uh as a fan of the
originals
i love where these characters have been
going yuji i gotta ask you when you when
you first
were playing chosen did you ever imagine
what his future would be like and that
he would you know
team up at some point in time with
daniel
no i thought uh once i was finished with
uh karate kid 2 um that was that and
then uh fast forward 30 odd years later
i got a call from the the writers saying
they want to bring me back into the fold
and i thought wow this is incredible
and then so when they brought me back to
be able to reunite with with ralph and
reunite with tamlet the media i'm like
oh my god
it was so
wonderful to
be able to work with them it was just
like we never left the
set up
too it was just this chemistry already
built in so yeah it was it was fantastic
thomas as silver you
this guy is the category of villain that
i like to call deliciously evil like
he'll kick a puppy but he's got a smile
on his face you know what i'm saying
do you ever get people in real life
coming up to you and actually being
upset with you
it's it's kind of the opposite carlos
you know i'm so amazed thinking oh you
know how they'll react to the villain
and instead they're like i love that
character it's like
and it happens
it just shocks me that they go what is
it about terry silva that's you know
tapping into so many people and and
cross-generational too which is just
amazing but uh i got a kick out of that
so there's something about him i think
that uh he's someone who enjoys what he
does you know he he wants the good fight
he wants to take it out and there's
still this passion and you know
guy underneath that just wants to
wanted daniel to be his friend and
wanted so you know wanted to be loved
and wanted to truly trying so hard not
to become um you know this this bad guy
character yeah
i was asking um
the five of us asked show low like what
was it like
seeing the og's up there doing their
thing rehearsing and he goes
it was cute
it was cute seeing him up there that was
his reaction
yuji do you have a response to that
because you two
together have this like electric
chemistry when you guys are on screen
together like what's your
what was that
experience like for you
uh well cute i got something for you to
show though
right here
uh no i tell you working with thomas was
such a joy uh my god it was uh
very um
oh god
i was so excited about the whole thing
because uh i got a chance to work with a
seasoned actor uh and and who was a
martial artist who um i knew that he
could handle himself
and and he would be safe and you know so
when we went at it i didn't have any
fear about this uh you know this whole
fight going south or anything like that
because
there was this tremendous amount of
trust that i had in common and i tell
you man the the stuff that he gave me
uh was was incredible and so you know
you have to give it right back and so if
the actor doesn't give you anything it
makes it a lot harder thomas you know
he's he's there for you he's always
present in the moment
off camera stuff he gives you 100
which i really appreciated so uh that
scene was just like fun for me
yes that was awesome guys thank you so
much for the time again such a pleasure
watching you in the season so cool thank
you all the best
you